one of the my favorite Clips you've ever
done is a clip you did I believe two
years ago was 19 things your father
should have taught you but never did and
at the end maybe we can do a little
rapid fire with that
um but I want to start with basically
your brand and just so the audience
understands you wrote a book it's called
the unplugged Alpha I would like to know
just so so everyone's on the same page
here what does it actually mean to be an
unplugged Alpha
yeah so I've identified four quadrants
that most guys fit into uh so if you can
sort of on your screen draw a big cross
on the left hand side you've got your uh
Alphas on the right hand side you got
your betas in the top they're unplugged
on the bottom they're plugged in so you
can have a plugged in Alpha you can have
a unplugged Alpha for example
um I did this longer podcast on my
unplugged Alpha podcast Series so for
those that really want to dive deep into
the weeds they can go look it up but
essentially the unplugged Alpha is the
best way to live your life if you want
to get everything that you want out of
life most of us start as either plugged
in betas or alphas and you know you can
kind of work up your way from there
gotcha and so uh you know a lot of the
stuff with the red pill Community the
manosphere they they draw a lot of the
metaphors from The Matrix I'm I'm
getting the vibe that this is also
basically something from the Matrix when
Keanu Reeves has to get unplugged is
that essentially where this came from
I actually had a guy from my community
named the title of the book so I liked
it and I ran with it so we're not giving
him Keanu Reeves a uh a shout out here
so I guess
I understand fully the difference
between Alpha and Beta And there's
different types of uh here the Pyramid
of uh of masculinity you know you've got
Alpha Beta Sigma Omega gamma all these
types of of types of men out there uh
but clarify what does it mean to be
plugged in or unplugged that's something
I'd like to unpack a little bit
well when you're plugged in you're sort
of sleep walking through life right you
kind of comply with everything they tell
you to do these are all the people that
you saw where face diapers stand on
their dots and comply with everything
they told us to do the last few years
right those that sort of questioned and
leaned back and said well hold on a
second let me just see what this is all
about let me just look at some numbers
let me evaluate the situation that's
what an unplug guy sort of does so
um it's really the difference between
you know being at the helm of your own
ship and basically being a dead fish
floating Downstream so the obviously
that this is as poignant as ever this
unplugged metaphor especially during
covid because you know the face diaper
analogy uh but prior to covid
it was maybe a little bit harder to
distinguish who was plugged in who was
not plugged in right because it kind of
kind of became very clear who's
questioning the rules that are kind of
coming down you know trust the science
all the stuff that's happened and
transpired over the last couple years
but prior to that how would you define
someone being plugged in or unplugged
from The Matrix so to speak
yeah I think your analogy there is is
spot on because the the scandemic really
highlighted those that that that were
part of the problem part of the system
and those that kind of ask questions
um you know prior to that it's your guys
you know your conventional guys that
would sit around during the holidays
when he was getting browbeat by his wife
and just sit there and go well happy
wife happy life golly gee you know those
are your standards sort of plugged in
sort of guys right they they just
subscribe to the narrative that's been
sold to them their entire lives through
a steady diet of you know Disney films
in Hollywood and media consumption and
all that sort of stuff when did you
become unplugged officially
um for me it was a rather lengthy
process I would say there was three
things that happened the first was my
divorce
um which was well over a decade ago now
and uh you don't really get what you
kind of expect to be I think most guys
that get divorced are just like well
that was like taking cutting a frying
pan to the forehead I didn't expect it
to go that way or it's a sort of operate
that way because
we kind of been told their entire lives
that men and women are equal and you
know we should treat everybody the same
sort of thing but that's not what you
really get when you go through the
divorce machine so that was the first
thing that sort of started to slap my uh
face
I guess the second thing was
um a bit of legislation that came down
the pipeline when I was still running my
debt business around 2010 to 2013 I
think it was
um and that was the banks and the credit
card companies that made a coordinated
and concerted effort to uh eliminate
options that helped Canadian consumers
get out of credit card debt
um which was a big surprise because you
think you know you've been told your
entire life the government's there to
sort of take care of you you vote for
them they're going to provide you with
roads they're going to provide you with
services and things that will allow you
to live the best possible life that you
can but through this lobbying effort I
discovered nope that's not how they work
uh and I guess the third thing was after
my divorce I got involved with this gal
for about three years I was a single mom
with a couple kids and uh you know a few
things happened that typically happened
to most guys during their relationships
with women that happened to me and I was
just like okay I gotta get my head
screwed on right you know there's all
these things that keep happening to me
in my life that's sort of uh destroy my
safe world theory and it's nobody else's
fault but mind because I'm an ownership
guy I always say you know do the work
and I sort of had to dive down this
Rabbit Hole of asking questions and you
know answers came to me when I started
asking questions gotcha so uh give me
the final question with the plugged and
unplugged give me the biggest benefit of
being unplugged and give me the biggest
I guess disadvantage of being plugged in
well I guess the biggest benefit is you
live life on your terms you know you can
then become the best version of yourself
um you're at the helm of your own ship
being plugged in you're just like
everybody else you're like about 95 of
the population to be honest with you
yeah you know if people are plugged into
society's lies well how do you know
you're when at what point do you realize
um like you're plugged in
you don't because you're plugged in
right so how does someone like it's
usually it's usually chaos for trauma so
for a lot of guys it's holy crap uh I
didn't think my wife would cheat on me
because we took vows together to love
and to hold and sickness and health in a
richer and poor why did she start
banging Kevin from sales right
um so it's some form of chaos that
usually breaks the safe oral theory for
them that they subscribe to and then and
then it forces them to realize okay
there's there's some new information
that I need to take in here all right
last question on this is uh what's step
one to getting unplugged you know how
they say like in the 12 Steps the first
thing is realizing that I do have a
problem or whatever it may be what's
step one to getting unplugged it's well
Step One is kind of two steps it's
you've got to see the world for what it
is and then you've like you've got to
see everybody else's [__] and then
you have to see your [__] right
never fun to have to look in the mirror
and be like buddy you are you are
plugged in you're 20 pounds overweight
you're broke as [__] you're not that
good looking and you're not that cool
and you're not in high school anymore so
it's kind of hard to
yeah watch any of my call-in segments
for my podcast a lot of guys are like
but I'm a high value guy and it's like
um no you make fifty thousand dollars a
year and you look like you're about 50
60 pounds overweight it's like let's
maybe start with that first uh first
step is recognizing the problem all
right cool I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out